a democratic congressman a member of the
house oversight and reform committee
mark desonia
he's also a member of the house
transportation and infrastructure
committee congressman welcome
thank you mike thanks for having me
you've seen the visuals coming from our
southern border both democrats and
republicans have been putting out
pictures and videos
how does the bind administration get a
handle on this crisis at the border
well i think all of us have to take all
of us in congress
they need to take a deep breath and
realize that this has gone
through multiple administrations i think
the byte administration
given the stress they're under is doing
the right thing the borders closed
don't come here and we need to create
more infrastructure to make sure we
manage it properly
should the president go to the border
sir
i i think it's good for all of us to go
to the border i haven't been
in the last few months but i'm anxious
to go again i've been there
many times in the past it's a real
this is a crisis manufactured in
washington d.c we need immigration
reform that secures our border do you
have hope of getting something done in
congress
immigration reform has been a tough
issue to get across the finish line as
you well know
well we have two bills in the house we
have sent multiple
ones over in the last session and now in
this one that we think will work
but the republican senators have to join
us uh given the filibuster so
it's really up to them okay to something
that's near and dear to your heart i
know you are involved with ground
transportation
also infrastructure your thoughts on the
upcoming infrastructure package
and do you want buy-in from your
republican colleagues sir
well latter part yes i am a former
republican and i registered to vote
i was a republican when i was first
elected to the city council 30 years ago
here in northern california i was
republican i left because of
what i saw in the party so yes we want
their support
this is a transformative piece of
legislation particularly for working
americans
it'll put working americans to work with
good pay
for multiple generations and will help
the overall economy
should it be strictly infrastructure or
do you worry about it becoming a
christmas tree with all
all other kinds of goodies being added
on
well i should be focused on
infrastructure but remember
infrastructure connects
lots of things uh and particularly our
new energy sources
uh which i've all been involved with
here in northern california for a long
time
we need to create new renewable
sustainable
uh energy sources and we're doing it
here in california and it's helping our
economy so
yes infrastructure first bridges and
roads and rail
but those are connected to their energy
sources in particular and how we live
i want to play a clip for you from
transportation secretary pete buddha
judge and i'll ask you to respond
if we believe in that so-called user
pays principle the idea that part of how
we pay for roads
is you pay based on how much you drive
the gas tax used to be the obvious way
to do it it's not anymore so
a so-called vehicle miles traveled tax
or mileage tax whatever you want to call
it
could be a way to do it congress do you
agree congressman do you agree
yeah when i was in the state legislature
i chaired the transportation housing
committee i was the author of a
first vmt bill here in california i
think that's a possibility
there are equity issues i think we have
to look at vis-a-vis people who have to
travel
hour and a half two hours each way to
get to work but those things i think we
can work through
so are you optimistic that there will be
bipartisan support
in the end on infrastructure or do you
think democrats are going to have
to do it on their own i'm optimistic by
nature just like president biden
but if we can't it's too much of an
urgency we need to go ahead but we
should listen
and i would just say i would agree with
senator brown your previous
uh guest on almost everything except you
know when they did the tax cut for the
wealthy
they didn't consult us at all either so
we we need to work together
uh but both sides have to take a step
towards each other and
so far i haven't seen that from
republican senators all right
congressman mark desanye of the great
state of california congressman
thanks for your time thanks for asking
me